that's not good these are the golden
guns photo I exported myself I should
probably reiterate that I am the lock
dude what oh no no no oh no no God Oh
God perfect shot is like haha have at
you
whoa where am I going okay oh [ __ ]
jump down here I dare you it wants Oh
God
whoa God
Oh be cool Oh be cool oh no these are
the golden guns aren't they hot [ __ ] I
think it protects ago that's right you
can jump on the head to kill we should
play towels
we should play dead body I love tower
fold you guys play tower fall mark mark
[Laughter]
no I won't go away [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] who
wants to sward you want to go brother
you want to go kill me with me let's
hang out
only two oh yeah yes oh [ __ ]
someone needs to grab that pistol in the
middle man get the pistol there you go
now murder him Wade I don't trust you
mark I was dead you got me yeah you got
me no no nope so wants to come up here
brass bobs to good pick your moments man
Oh God Zook
[Laughter]
I forgot that it's hard because why is
the throw away these aren't the actual
golden guns are gold Oh Ricky's walking
perfectly yes perfect Tom your grenade
was fake and it was [ __ ] it was
apparently it wrong there are duds there
are dozens I've got a float I've got a
laser for some [ __ ] reason
Oh piddly pushy gun that sucks oh [ __ ]
oh whoa you make us go crazy oh yeah oh
it's it's a glowing hook oh I had no
idea I have a grapples myself you wanna
go bro you want to go where else yeah
you wanna go brah you want to go huh oh
you could throw the bananas and they
make like banana peels kill me
I'm the laser man no it's a pop gun
I burned everyone these penises Oh oh
you can push each other off the map I
mean I think those orbs were deadly okay
now how do you play this game we don't
run around no [ __ ] you Wade oh no no no
no no no no come on no no no I was doing
good I killed more you guys than anyone
else did mark I think it's around
I know but shut up it's still I'm good
dicks
a ste can afford to win a few it's fine
shut up I'm gonna win them all [ __ ] oh
no oh no I don't understand oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] who
wants to come here building you survived
[Laughter]
chainsaw murder do you guys have some
[ __ ] man oh [ __ ] you I do it again mark
no come on it's a bunch of baloney ball
you're a bunch of baloney I'm such a
fool
these only have one shot each yeah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
would you avoid that don't kill me don't
kill me no kill
Oh [ __ ] I should be winning more
yeah here you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh I'm
out all right apparently my camera my
camera where am I Oh get murdered [ __ ]
Oh No our chainsaws cancel each other
out
whoa they don't cancel each other out
Jack's a cheater Jack's a cheater
Jack teetered she's heard all over the
place he heard his laces Tom I'm not a
cheater
oh come on I was gonna win that it's
[ __ ] I like I was the like I fired
everybody's oh come on I've killed so
many of you so many come on no one so
far
shut up I can do it you want to see the
world's greatest comeback kinda happen
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no oh no the door was
gonna open
Oh No what's the Porter Porter
oh no I wasted it oh no [ __ ] winds
damaged truce oh I have a [ __ ] musk
you know Jesus no no so what are the
odds that this has oh here we go again
I gotta mow get out of here [ __ ] I think
me and bobert's fight right now you
didn't get the armor Oh Oh what I went
armor on I win why'd you die shut up
[ __ ] you how about you Oh God
[Music]
why asked me if I reloaded you [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
why did okay I feel like they want their
Jack no ah
wait didn't maybe once is great we
didn't win oh I told you you want a
couple come on great duck come on you
[ __ ]
No Oh tiebreaker deathmatch deathmatch I
think that's a deathmatch I don't know
what happens deathmatch sold me on
deathmatch Oh God oh wait
jeonse shut up